what are you doing for sound out there I
mean especially it's so windy what did
you find to be the best for capturing
clean audio its wits windy and you can
get these things called sound blimps
that will go over your shotguns that
have massive protection that will do an
amazing job the problem is you're on a
boom pole you're recording to a recorder
we we actually rented a whole sound
devices system a 744 burr recording
system we actually had like a wireless
setup so our camera could be independent
from the boom ultimately like the stuff
that we shot with that full sound rig
didn't get used as much as the stuff
that was just off camera was on the
little cameras because you know it's
it's the difference between I'm here
with my camera and I'm documenting my
experience and I'm one and I'm just
roaming compared with it's sort of setup
we have the boom out we have the sound
recording we know what we're doing it's
planned and so we found that just you
know people doing whatever out there
ended up being the best thing and it's
tough in the Edit we just had you know
this you know just clips your your audio
because the because of the win and that
was tough to edit around there's a
couple moments in the film where you get
to experience that full wind thing but
not that much because it's really hard
to listen to so so you felt that it
really tainted the reaction of people to
see this full film crew versus somebody
with just their generic phone and it was
much more organic yeah yeah I mean I
mean when you have a bigger camera
there's sort of a self-conscious things
that happen people are aware and all of
a sudden people are aware then it's sort
of like bringing you out of what's real
and so our our film what ended up in the
final cut is real it's like this
multi-perspective thing of like what
really happened and you know there are
these amazing shots with the red cameras
that are on tripods getting good sound
you know it's just it's a lot of effort
to go through with all that
and probably two people were really
hamming it up for the camera to theirs
you get to extremes right yeah you get
you get people that don't want to be on
camera and that's the thing at Burning
Man everyone has their own rights and so
you have to ask permission and you have
to make sure that people know that
you're there and know that you're
shooting and you know some of the shoots
that we did we had hundreds of people
that were all involved in our shoots we
have this amazing art for the sky
project where you know hundreds of
people all made a giant tree and we did
this redwood resurrection project with
this huge tree that was made out of
people you know fell down and came back
up and we had this big dance and that
was you know something we had planned
and shot and this whole thing you know
and other things out there that are
equally as profound but you're just on
your handheld camera and you're just
talking to the camera like saying what's
up and sharing your experience
you